It seems that erasing the back has been successful without any problems, Master.
There is
a new
organization with extraordinary scientific power. Maybe we're just their
creations,
but I'm an experimental subject to complete successful works like jf and mari.
I couldn't do it,
but as time went by, for some reason only me and the m24 underwent a special evolution.
I'm the only
one who survived.
m 24 It's
small.
What are you going to do now
?
What are you doing? You protected my students. It
's thanks to you and your friends that they only got hurt.
But I'm not as good a person as you guys
Trust is not
important First of all, the important thing is the decision of the star,
then it's free u 6 I was
just thinking of increasing the number of people  I'm
not distributing the pop
poo rank Coming in. Are you sure you're going to do that thing that you shared last night?
How are you?
[Music]
What's
wrong with
me?  I'm scared, so where's my grandfather? What does that mean
? Are you looking forward to the dancing stars?
n I'm
going to go play with my friends and go home.
I'm going to clear the room to the professor
.
I live in my boss's place, but
if I take a detour on the 4th, I'll be worried, right?
I don't know how long it will last
I see
[music]
plank
The world has really
changed The time the master was asleep
wasn't short
Had they come in, it would have made me do more, I
wouldn't have taken a wrong turn, I
would have been allowed to take a detour of my soul
.  I'm sorry, I will prepare it as soon as possible